think ahead it gets your mind off what's
going on today
you have to have interest away from the
narrow thing of what you do you have to
be somebody
who's interesting to yourself but you
have to be somebody who somebody else
wants to talk to
you know i always think that you should
start with the problem that you're
trying to solve in the world
and not start with um deciding that you
want to build a company
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
every single day we'll be grinding it
out a so
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside youtube
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn these seven
rich people habits that you need to try
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one think ahead
with john paul de jouria if you focus on
what's going on right now in your life
and how bad things are
that has all your attention whatever has
your attention
happens so if your attention is there in
a fair area it's going to continue that
way
so i say to you look ahead we are going
to be opening up again we are going back
to work again
all of us it's only a matter of time so
look at it
when we're ready to go back am i ready
to go back
what can i do now in the meantime
whatever business you're in your
restaurant your salons whatever
you're in can i call some of my
customers up and say hi how you doing
i'll be all ready for you in such and
such
a day think ahead it gets your mind off
what's going on today
and what's going on today isn't good if
it's not okay
it's not the end you are what you think
many books were written on this
as a man thinketh is one of them that
was written 70 80 years ago
another one by gosh by napoleon hill was
think and grow rich more or less
thinking about yourself and where you
want to go in life and
one of the greatest books i think ever
written was how to win friends and
influence people
by dale carnegie it's 80 years old but
it applies
when you read books like that about how
to treat others
it also tells you how to treat yourself
because they talk about positive thought
positive conversation
habit number two be rigorous with robin
sharma
when i watch people right now there is
what i call the collective
unprofessionalization of business
if you look at people let's say at
airports you look at gate agents
they're chatting with their friends
you go into a shoe store and rather than
welcoming you into the shoe store
the person the person behind the counter
is checking their facebook page
you go to a restaurant and rather being
attentive to you and your loved ones
the people are chit chatting and
gossiping and looking at
videos of dancing cats
or bloopers or bleepers or
weepers or whatever they're called and
my point is simply this is an incredibly
gorgeous opportunity for you in this
world of
so much unprofessionalism where people
are just clocking it in
versus bringing it on where people are
lost in this trance of distraction
suffering from collective attention
deficit disorder
you can operate and apply this second
mentality
rather than being superficial be really
rigorous
be a professional if you're not over
prepared for a meeting
you're unprepared spend a lot of your
free time
reading and learning about your career
about your industry about the work that
you do
get a mentor if you are serious about
being
rigorous around your craft make the time
at least once a week
to pull out your journal and deconstruct
your week just deconstruct the way you
do things
when you are working on a project don't
just slap it together don't just rush
right through it there is such
an attraction to doing things quickly
now because everything is quick
you know messaging is coming to us so
quickly we can access
information so quickly we can access
entertainment so quickly we get our food
so quickly
and as a result of that we're we do our
work too
quickly okay this is the not
superficial the second mentality the
rigorous mentality
go deep versus wide go deep versus wide
go deep versus wide if you look at any
great master
they were mono maniacally focused on
going deep
around one thing khalil gibran
wrote one of my favorite books the
prophet i heard he carried it around
with him for five
years to get every single word
right that's a craftsperson you know
when you look at the great athletes
i recently was in san francisco and i
watched steph curry play
steph curry was fluid like a ballerina
on the court
you know i have nba superstars coming to
my live events
and when i watch them they are so
focused on going deep
around their skill versus being all
things to everyone
habit number three have integrity with
grant cardone
i think what i do is and i talk about
this in seller be sold i've been a sales
guy for a long time and i i just learned
early on
and i was terrible at sales 17 years old
18 19 part-time part-time sales guy was
i was awful when i finally realized that
sales was the only job i could get at 25
years old
i'm just like dude i just got to tell
people the truth because i can't do all
these tricks
the nlp the and look if it works for you
good whatever but
the mirroring the matching they ask a
question you ask a question the hot
potato i've heard all these strategies
and i'm like dude i just can't do it i'm
just going to be me hey guys i'm i'm
moving from la
i'm out of work i'm looking for
opportunity i'm trying to move my family
here my name's louis curtis
2008 beat me up i got to get my family
out of la real estate's impossible i
can't buy it there it's out priced out
of the market
and i'm here in pueblo because i think
there's opportunity here
and that's all i'm looking for no
handouts no help i don't
i got an old truck with me i got no
money i left my kids with
you got to have your story so people
enroll but you also have to be talking
to the right audience
i only spent time with people that were
able capable qualified
i spent no time i was in a meeting once
in pueblo
i walked into the meeting assessed the
situation and bounced
i said guys i'm done i'm out of here
boom and i walked out and and my partner
at that time
you'll see it later in the later shows
he's like what just happened i'm like
there's nothing here bro there's no
money here
there's no there's no opportunity here
and i'm on a clock i couldn't tell him
on one o'clock i couldn't tell
i couldn't tell anybody so i had these
little secrets going on
so you know how do you enroll people
it's like you got to get enrolled
you know my my personal integrity and
ethics
is why i can sell so hard and because i
believe in my product i believe in my
investment vehicle i believe in my
company i don't trick people
screw people like 35 years i've been in
business
there's not one person in 35 years that
says i owe them money
there's people that try to get stuff
from me using lawyers and [ __ ] but
there's nobody that can say i
ever financially damaged them in any way
not a penny
and so that that that allows me to go
back into the world
and push it allows me to sell tickets
for big prices
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here habit
number four
write down principles with ray dalio
you need to have your own principles
i'll explain some things
but i'm going to share some of my
principles i hope they're helpful to you
there are things that have worked for me
um that i've written down over a period
of time but number one
i want to describe this experience to
you whenever you're in a situation
and that if you take the time after that
situation
and you write down your criteria for
making decisions
then you will have that for the next
time that thing comes along
and this what happens is the same things
happen over and over again
for the same kind of reasons but you
don't see that you're
operating um in a way where you know you
take them one at a time
and so i would recommend to you that
you write those principles down when you
do that you start you think about them
in a deeper way
and then the people that are in your
lives then
start to understand how you're behaving
and they can be partners in that idea
meritocratic decision making so that
they can also say
is that the best way to operate and deal
with that situation
and so you start to think in a more
principled way rather than all of these
bits and pieces of different things
habit number five be interesting with
lloyd blankfein
you also have to be a complete person
you have to be interesting
you have to have interest away from the
narrow thing of what you do you have to
be somebody
who's interesting to yourself but you
have to be somebody who somebody else
wants to talk to
and um you know people in these jobs and
things like that you don't get locked up
in a carol you know chained to a desk
fed you know food under the door
just churning out spreadsheets nobody's
gonna ask you to churn out this
spreadsheet even even if you're good at
it
you have to be a complete person i think
the order of things
should be in your early life
[Music]
and your earliest part like college i
think it should be for becoming a
complete person
and then get more and more folks you
don't want to start out focus
now and get narrow from there now is the
time
when you should you know people i think
should take and and i know it it doesn't
feel like that in other words and by the
way
your big brother or sister in this firm
may not say that to you
but look at what really they did look
who they are in other words if you want
to look at who's successful in the firm
or in any other firm go through that and
really look at who they were
and sometimes i this comes up to me in a
lot of context somebody will say
oh my goodness let's go i want to be a
two-year analystic
goldman in two years at a private equity
firm i'm going to go to bill and do that
and i said
because that's the mantra and that's the
proto and that's the thing and i said by
the way those people who you want to
emulate in the world
who are those successful people who are
going to hire you for that two-year
what did they do that's not what they
did
some of them were in government for 15
years some of them worked at goldman
sachs for 20 years and really became
very very adept at something
before they were but they didn't do what
you what
they didn't do what they're saying and
they're not lying to you if you slap the
lie detector on them they'd be telling
it's just not the narrative i think you
have to be
more i once i said this a rift on this
in another context i know some people
saw it
i'm i like to read history and i like to
read the biographies part of history
because i like to know what people
really did
that get it because you'd find that
nobody that
nobody took that kind of a straight line
and so when people hear
and worry oh my god i'm getting out of
college already and i don't know how to
you know i don't know how to uh you know
discount a cash flow
i mean i promise you
you'll if you're here for 15 minutes
you'll know how to do that as and and
and having studied it in college for
four years
and then having your 15-year minutes
here learning it won't make you know it
more
and and six months after you're here no
one will remember
who who did it but if you but if you
have a more breathy kind of a
an academic career where you learn more
stuff and you're more interesting and
you read [ __ ] you know you read a
shakespeare play and you took an art
course that's going to serve you well
not just in your personal life in your
business lives you should be a more
interesting person
habit number six be honest with yourself
with mark cuban
i've had businesses though that have
failed before that
um and when you don't have any customers
that's your answer yeah yeah you know
because even if it's a labor of love
you know i i tried to play the piano on
the guitar for a while and we had a band
called the not so human beans
there's a reason why you never heard of
it that's awesome
it was a great name but yes and there
was a time to quit so
when you don't have any customers and
people aren't reacting to it the same
way you are
one of the one of the challenges of
being an entrepreneur is that we all lie
to ourselves
you know we're the best we're the we're
the fastest
you know the greatest the this or the
that is if you find yourself always
describing your company
and how you're different in terms of
errs and s
you know you've got issues and you're
probably lying to yourself you have to
be brutally honest you have to ask
yourself
if it wasn't me if i was on the outside
looking in you know what would i say
about this company and if you're not
able to do that
that's a bigger problem but you just
have to be brutally honest and habit
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips
is solve a problem with mark zuckerberg
you know i always think that you should
start with
the problem that you're trying to solve
in the world and not start with
um deciding that you want to build a
company right the best companies that
get built
are things that are trying to drive some
kind of social change even if it's
just local in one place uh you know more
than starting out because you want to
make a bunch of money or
have a lot of people working for you or
or build some company in some way so
you know i always think that this is
kind of a perverse thing about silicon
valley in a way
which is that you know people decide
often that they want to start a company
before they even decide what they want
to do
and that just feels really backwards to
me and you know for anyone who's had the
experience of actually building a
company
you know that you go through some really
hard things along the way and i think
part of what
gets you through that is believing in
what you're doing
and knowing that what you're doing is is
really
delivering a lot of value for people um
and and that's i think how the best
companies end up getting made now i've
got some special bonus clips that i
think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
when you just watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
need to take some action
but when you watch a video you get
motivated and you create
a specific plan of action that number
jumps from 35 percent
to 91 chance of you following through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video
your number jumps to 95 chains of you
actually following through on the plan
you set for yourself
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate you people don't show
up for one of three reasons
number one is you're afraid you're
afraid of rejection you're afraid of
failure you're afraid of it not working
out and so you just don't show up
number two is you're not consistent you
show up some days but you don't show up
other days because you don't have the
routines
and habits in place to make you show up
consistently every single day
and number three is you don't want to
you don't want to show up because you
don't actually enjoy the thing that
you're about to do
you would rather procrastinate on it
because you don't love it
and showing up is more painful than just
sitting around
so my goal today with this video is to
help you bust through these so that you
can show
up for life and have the impact that you
want to have
so i think the fear of showing up is
actually a good thing it means that you
are doing something different something
outside your comfort zone something that
is that is not normal that is new and
that's good you want to be pushing the
envelope
if there was nothing that you were
afraid to show up to today tomorrow next
week then you're not growing you're not
learning you're not pushing against your
boundaries and comfort zones
and so even today i had to show up but
and again it should be every single day
so today
i was procrastinating on sending out an
email to grant
as well as a couple other people where
i'm looking at doing more collaborations
more work on my youtube channel more
cross pollination connection to other
successful youtubers
to help the whole entrepreneur youtube
community grow right i want to get the
message out there i want to be
playing a bigger game and so i emailed
grant and emailed four other people with
a new idea that i had
so when the idea was first suggested to
me about doing this and reaching out
i had a little bit of nerves like okay
it's gonna require an ask
i might get rejected it may not work out
and i had it scheduled for today because
it was my youtube day and so i look at
the list today like uh
maybe i should start with one person or
two people or just pick the easy people
and just the fact that i felt that just
the fact that that was one of the
reasons meant
i had to go and do five i had to do a
bigger number i had to go after
the harder people i had to do the people
that i thought
may say yes may say no may make me look
bad if they say no
and a lot of it is just head games the
honest truth is
grant's probably not gonna care grant's
probably gonna say yes
like 98 chance he says yes and he passes
on to somebody on his team
we start working together and we create
the collaboration uh one percent chance
he ignores it
and one percent chance he says no but
it's not the logical rational things
that hold us back it's the emotional
fearful things and so what i've trained
myself to do is anytime i feel that
that that oh my god it may not work out
then i have to do it
i have to do it i have just to show
myself because the worst thing you can
do
is get to the edge of the cliff and say
you're gonna jump and then not jump
it's better not to catch that you're
nervous it's better not to even come up
with the idea
to just float around in ignorance
ignorance is bliss
than to catch it and then play small and
so as soon as you catch it i've trained
myself i want you to do the same thing
as soon as you catch it train yourself
to do it even if it doesn't work out
just training yourself that you don't
back down when you are afraid
so i'm going to give you a three-step
process that you can follow to help you
conquer your fears to help you show up
consistently
every day let's do it number one is tell
yourself that you do scary things
one of the biggest reasons why people
don't advance their ideas forward is
because
it's scary it's scary you're afraid
amazing that is now no longer an
acceptable reason
you do scary things you love scary
things you embrace scary things you want
to do scary things
this isn't just a mindset trick it's
actually true
you want to do scary things you do
what's the opposite of scary things
the opposite of scare if you walk
through life and you're never scared of
anything
it's not that you're super confident no
it means that you're living inside your
comfort zone
it means you're only doing things that
have zero fear that you have absolute
certainty in
because you've done it before you're
bored
you're living inside your bubble and you
need to break out because that means
you're photocopying your life
every single day if there's nothing in
your calendar
that makes you scared you hate your life
and so pay attention to the language pay
attention to how you talk to yourself
pay attention to when you feel afraid
and as long as it's not against your
code of ethics or doing something stupid
don't go jump out of an airplane without
a parachute because you're afraid
right most of the things you're afraid
of are not life-threatening
teach yourself that you do scary things
you love scary things and you're not
allowed to use as an excuse anymore for
not taking action
number two is think what makes you sore
what is the thing that gets you feeling
bold alive
confident ready to take action wanting
to show up to life
what is it i go through five s's every
morning as part of my morning routine
the verse is sing and then sun and then
sore and then sweat
and then scare the most important part
is sore though it's a thing that i do
to make me come alive that makes me want
to soar and so for me what i do is i
think about an entrepreneur that i
helped yesterday
and then i pull up my phone and then i
record a message and i share that to my
youtube stories instagram stories
twitter linkedin i put it everywhere
i need to feel like the work that i do
matters
right now i'm just talking to a camera
i'm just talking into a camera right now
and and later it's gonna be edited and
it's gonna be thrown up on youtube and
lots of people are gonna watch the video
that's that's crazy it's hard to
imagine because i'm just sitting here in
my office talking into a camera
and so i need to remember that the work
i do has purpose that this matters to
some people
right that people rely on my videos
every day is a part of their routine
and that helps make me sore so i wake up
just like everybody else i'm tired
i'm i don't know what time it is
sometimes even this morning i woke up i
didn't even know what day it was is it
the weekend is it i had no idea
right you wake up i'm not coming out of
the day saying yeah
my gosh let's go right that's not how
anybody wakes
up nobody that's not how grant cardone
wakes up evan carmichael tony robbins
nobody that's not how we wake up
the difference is the habits that you
set on a daily basis
to demand that success to demand that
you show up
and so what is the thing that helps make
you sore maybe it's remembering the
impact you want to have maybe it's
sharing a message
to youtube to instagram to linkedin
maybe it's doing an act of service maybe
it's meditation maybe it's reading maybe
it's watching these videos what is it
that makes you feel like you want to
soar and then don't
randomly hope that it happens demand
that it's part of your morning routine
because if you woke up and did the thing
to make you sore to make you feel bold
confident unstoppable and you did that
every day for the next year
your life will be dramatically different
you will not recognize the person who
you used to be
the challenge is you're not consistent
in soaring and so i need you to make
that part of your morning routine
and then number three is understand what
is your michael jordan talent what could
you be the greatest in the world
at you could be the greatest the
greatest
of all time at something you are but
what is that thing
most people are living way below the
potential because they settled
you settled too early you settled
because you were pressured you settled
because you were afraid
you settled because you ran out of time
or at least you felt you did
that's not an acceptable answer anymore
you could be the greatest in the world
at something and if you're
procrastinating on something it's either
because you're afraid of the thing
in which case you need to go and do it
because you do scary you do afraid right
back to tip number one
or two you just don't like it you
procrastinate because you don't like it
and if you continue to do work
that you don't like you're never going
to be the best
because you're going up against people
who love it the one thing
i i'm not smarter than anybody else but
i can outwork you
and my key to success for
you or for anybody else is make sure
you're the first one in there every day
and the last one to leave
don't ever take a lunch break or go to
the bathroom you keep working
you never know when that opportunity is
going to come along and at solomon
brothers
the managing partner of the company bill
solomon was the
second person in i was the only other
one in the big trading room
so if he had needed to borrow a match in
those days people smoked cigars
and if he wanted to ask something about
a newspaper or a stock
he came over and so we became buddies i
would never have
gotten to talk to the managing partner
of a big company
on a first name basis if it wasn't for
the fact that the two of us are there
billy i'm getting coffee would you like
some
and i can bring you that and at the end
of the day the number two guy john good
friend he was the last one to leave
except for me and we'd share a cab going
uptown or take the subway train going
uptown together
and you know every opportunity ever had
it was
i think a lot a lot of them was because
i was there at the time
and that's the one thing you can control
you can you can't control your luck but
the harder you work the luckier you get
you can't control that you're the
smartest guy they'll always be somebody
smarter
but if you're there then you
absorb things you put things together in
a ways that if you didn't have all that
experience
it's like skiing i've said reading a
book on skiing
doesn't teach you how to ski you got to
go and you gotta
ski and get lots of miles under your
skis
and incidentally if you don't fall
you're not skiing hard enough and you're
not learning anything so
if your career has ups and downs i got
fired didn't turn out so bad
but you know you can start a little
business and maybe it doesn't work and
after a while you've got to say be smart
say hey i tried it
don't let your ego get in the way i
can't keep doing this i've got to earn a
living
but you know a year from now i'm going
to come up with a better idea and then
i'll go back and do it again
and have that drive to look at the
bright side and i've
with the exception of um i've always
i've never it's never been a day that i
haven't looked forward to going into
work even the days i knew i was going to
get beaten up even the day i knew i was
going to get fired
i'd never been fired before i wonder
what it's like okay let's go find out
yeah and i've never looked back i i find
it fascinating people spend and we're
doing this in this country
we're spending all our time trying to
blame people and figure out why we got
to where we are now
rather than focusing on how you get out
of where we are now and make it better
and successful people look for the
future
and unsuccessful people look to the back
by far the best investment you can make
is in yourself
i mean that for example communication
skills i tell the students that come
that
they're going to graduate schools and
business and they're learning all these
complicated formulas and all that
if they just learn to communicate better
and both in writing and
in person they increase their value at
least 50 percent no
i mean if you can't communicate somebody
who says
you know it's like winking at a girl in
the dark nothing happens you know
basically and and
you have to be able to get get both your
ideas
and uh and that's that's relatively easy
i did it myself
with the dale carnegie of course some
people wish i'd taken a shorter course
now
in terms of my talking later on but it
it's just hugely important and you if
you invest in yourself
nobody can take it away from you
everybody that i meet who ask me
sort of how to how to organize
themselves what i do is i tell them to
say yes
say yes to things just say yes hey just
say yes figure out a way to do it find a
way to say yes to things say yes to
invitations to a new country
say yes to meet new friends say yes to
learn something new yes it's how you get
your first job your next job your spouse
even your kids
even if it's a bit edgy a bit out of
your comfort zone saying yes means that
you'll do something new meet someone new
and make a difference
yes lets you stand out on a crowd be the
optimist
see the glass full be the one that
everyone comes to
yes is what keeps us all young ambition
the desire to go somewhere the myopic
focus that there's something you're here
for a reason and you want to get that
done
whatever that is for you it's never work
when you're pursuing your ambition
it's just it's just who you are it's
your it's your soul it's your being
and i think that's what makes great
entrepreneurs are great leaders they
they want to get up in the morning they
want to do what they
you know what their ambition is telling
they have to do ambition is a drive it's
a vision it's a drive
life is full of different risks i think
that when you think about the things
that you will regret when you're 80
they are almost always the things that
you did not do
they are acts of omission they're not
you're not very rarely are you going to
regret something that you did and it
failed and didn't work or whatever
but the acts of omission the thing you
know it's not and again i'm not just
talking about business things it's like
you know uh i loved that person and i
never
told them and then you know 50 years
later like why didn't i
tell her you know why didn't i go after
it so that's the kind of
that's the kind of life regret that is
very hard to
uh be happy about when you're telling
yourself
in a private moment that story of your
life
i'm very lucky to have been in silicon
valley and silicon valley is very lucky
to have been able to benefit from you
know the semiconductor
boom and then software and now internet
and mobile
um i mean i think it's
uh there's a huge amount of luck there
but the luck also comes from taking
many shots uh you know so many
failures you know if i told you all the
dumb things that i did
um you know we'd have to have much
longer session uh
and and the successes you know they
often are
chance i mean i mentioned the google
brain work that they were just off in
the corners like okay fine just
you know do your thing uh our
you know verily which is uh our
subsidiary that does a wide range of
healthcare innovation now
uh really started with this glucose
sensing contact lens project
and that was another one where i said uh
this fellow babak and brian otis who
were working on it
uh you know and they wanted to put a
computer in a contact lens and i was
like you know what that sounds crazy but
you know you go do your crazy thing you
know you can only have a couple people
work on it i'm not going to give you a
lot of resources
uh but uh you know sure if you put a
computer in contact lens good for you
and yet here they are uh you know a few
years later and they're you know running
uh you know they're doing serious
studies now they have a big partnership
with
artists and alcon uh and they are
um you know hopefully going to bring
those to market
alongside with a bunch of other projects
that that has spawned
and i didn't know anything about that
and i never would have predicted or
guessed
that i think we're just lucky to have
the environment that tolerates
you know making lots of risky bets and
tolerating the failures that inevitably
result
everyone has a gift everyone can
contribute if they're empowered and so
that's the secret
have a society have institutions have
people
that empower others that enable them
to find their gift turn it into valued
skills
and then apply it in a way that enables
them to succeed by contributing to
others
and see how simple this is yeah and
i mean the problem is you need a society
that is relatively based on
the principles of equal rights and
mutual benefit where people succeed by
assisting each other
and everyone has the opportunity to
realize their potential
now that's utopian there's no society
that's been
perfect at that but even ones through
history
that have had a small degree of that
then
what these people can do that no one
suspected could do anything have done
extraordinary things
and change societies and so that's what
we try to do
is go find those people to solve a
problem to eliminate an
injustice and then back them and combine
our capabilities with theirs
to enable them to do even more to help
even more people
what i call this is applying the
principles of human progress
this involves three different things it
because
it requires believing in yourself
believing in other people
empowering them from the bottom up
having them realize
that no one's good at everything we're
all just good at a few things
so we need to partner with people who
have complementary capabilities
so this gets to frederick douglass's
philosophy that made him such a great
uh social entrepreneur to unite with
anybody to do right
and no one to do wrong so those are some
of our guidelines
but as i say then the starting point in
all this
is to recognize that everybody can
participate in this
everybody can contribute and succeed if
you're a closed system
you close yourself off from the rest of
the world you try to do everything
yourself
and you're going to fall behind you
probably die
right quickly and that's true for an
organization
and that's true for society so what does
that tell us
it tells us things about immigration
tells us things about free speech and
open
inquiry it tells us about trade it
relates to ricardo's law of comparative
advantage division of labor
comparative advantage when that started
to be allowed
practice rather than everybody having to
do everything themselves
that's when prosperity started to take
off and poverty started to decline in
the 18th century
it's very important to to seek out to
actively seek out
and listen very carefully to negative
feedback
um and this is something that people
tend to
avoid because it's it's painful yeah um
but but i think this is a very common
mistake
is to to not actively seek out
and listen to uh negative feedback what
do you do that do you go into forums do
you go into twitter like what are your
areas where you go to look for feedback
on let's say the tesla well
it's like everyone i talk to is um in
fact when um
when friends get a product i said look i
don't tell me what you like tell me what
you don't like
right um and and because otherwise your
friend is not going to tell you what he
doesn't like
right this is going to say oh i love
this and that and and then
and leave out the this is the stuff i
don't like list because too much of your
friend one
you know it doesn't want to offend you
so um
so you really need to
[Music]
to to to to sort of coax negative
feedback um
and you should you know that if somebody
is your is your friend or at least
not your enemy and they're giving you
negative feedback um
then they may be wrong but it's coming
from a good place
and sometimes even your enemies give you
good negative feedback i spent an
unusual amount of time with my
grandparents and especially with my
grandfather on the ranch so he had a
ranch in south texas
and i would spend my summers there from
age 4 to
16. and they when i was four they were
taking me
for the summer to kind of give my
parents a break you know it's sort of
because they were so
young and it was useful
i was a handful i'm sure and uh
anyway he he he he created the illusion
for me
when i was four years old but i was
helping him on the ranch
which of course could not have been true
but i believed it
and um and then as by the time i was 16
of course i was actually helping on the
ranch i
you know i could i can fix prolapsed
cattle i can
you know we did all of our own
veterinary work some of the cattle even
survived
and uh we fixed windmills and laid you
know water pipelines and built fences
and
barns and fixed that fixed the bulldozer
that you guys talked about
and so one of the things that's so
interesting about
that lifestyle and about my grandfather
is he did everything himself you know he
didn't call a vet
if one of the animals was sick he
figured out what to do himself
and uh so what does it mean no
delegation being resourceful i think is
the you know that
you can always you can't if there's a
problem there's a solution
and of course as you as you mature and
and
get into the business world and anything
you do on a team you very quickly
realize that
it's not about just your own
resourcefulness it's about
team resourcefulness i discovered at an
early age i didn't think i was much good
at anything
and uh but my father did bit me a big
favor
he had me working in all my spare time
from the time i was six
because he he announced he didn't want
his sons to
be country club moms he wanted us to
feel
grateful for everything and entitled to
nothing
and and for whatever reason when you say
working he didn't give you some cushy
office job in the company no no no not
particularly at age six i started out
digging dandelions and when i say dig
dandelions you don't pull them out
you dig them down and you have to get
the entire route or they'll come
right back and i remember there was a
club and a swimming pool across the
street from us and i'm out there in 105
degree heat
digging these and i could hear my
friends
my little six-year-old friends they're
swimming and jumping off the diving
board and i could recognize
each one squeal was different of joy
and i'm thinking why does my father
hate me and their fathers love them
i found out that if you don't and then
and then i of course graduated to
shoveling out stalls
and milking cows and that doesn't sound
like
much work but oh it's it's hard work
so i would milk cows before school and
then again after school
milk or cows and digging post holes and
all these things
but i discovered that much later
that if if you don't learn to do dirty
jobs if you don't learn
unpleasant work you by the time you're
in your 30s you never learn to work
productively and so he was doing me a
huge favor
so it was beyond the work ethic
it taught you how to work productively
and how to work with others
in mutual benefit for example if a group
of you during a dirty job
you don't try to stick it to them make
them do more then they'll try to do it
to you
and the work goes on and on you want to
work together
to get it done as efficiently as
possible you want to understand who your
customer
is how do what does my customer want
what does he value i better do this the
right way or i'll have to do it again
you better stay on top of yourself and
and really
measure unless people measure themselves
you don't get any better you cannot
succeed
unless you are really holding yourself
accountable and owning outcomes
believe me i've seen plenty of people at
microsoft various places in the tech
industry
brilliant people who when it came time
to execute and actually count success
and maybe not so much maybe not so much
you get in order to do that you have to
actually know what the goal is
if the goal was to get the 450 million
users
and then sell the facebook whatsapp did
a hell of a job
right i mean that that's not a i mean
it's a hell of a job at 19 billion 55
people that's a hell of a job
but you have to decide what outcome do
you want
bill gates was offered seven and a half
million dollars to sell all of microsoft
in 1979.
it would have been a rich guy if he had
taken it
richer if he didn't but a rich guy but
even putting that aside the impact on
society wouldn't have been the same
we had discussions with facebook about
buying facebook but zuckerberg knew
what he viewed as a an outcome that he
really desired and was willing to put in
the blood sweat and tears just like we
were
so execution and measurement are
hugely important and yet people let
themselves
off the hook grant rant of the day
the one you need to live with wake up to
every day is that right there
okay beat the sun up folks you got to
beat the sun up if you can't beat up the
roll-up of the sunnah
you're going to get beat up in life okay
i've been doing this for a long time now
i'd say beat that thing up that monster
out there that warms this planet
that nourishes and gives us light
but you can't live a 10x life if you're
not beating the sun up
so many of you complain about how much
time you have you don't have time man
because you don't beat the sun
up get started early and when you get
started early that means you need to
shut it down early okay shut it down
early so you get sleep i was i was i was
asleep last night at nine o'clock
so i could beat the sun up tomorrow this
morning and see
the world wake up with me today the 18
founders of alibaba a lot of people
think they are legendary something
wow you all hibaba founders you must be
super good at
honestly most of us cannot find the jobs
early days
we're not that smart none of us graduate
from a
you know a great university um
but the thing is that we are ready to
learn
we believe in the future if we work
together if we learn we've improved
we'll be there i told them for the first
year everybody forget about
that you will be vp vice president right
you will always be a tiny manager in
your life
because if we're successful people will
hide they will be smarter than us
if we only hire people who are stupid
than us then we'll be in trouble
right so when we hire people who are
smarter than us the company will grow
and you will be happy because this is
the mission that we have
so i would say there's no best
people in the world that is suit ready
for you
the best people is always you you find
the right people
working together training him developing
him and
he training you he then you have a
chance to build a team
i told myself the same thing i tell
everybody one
you're 21 22 23 years old right
you don't have to figure it out right
now don't try
right you spend all this money sorry
um paying to learn
now it's your chance to get paid to
learn you don't need the perfect job you
just need to go somewhere where you'll
learn
and start to be exposed to different
ideas and now it's not like you know
when when greg 40 years ago was
graduating
and me five years ago you know it was
like get a career
and you know the pressure was get a
career go work for
ibm or general motors and get a pension
those days are gone
people can't even pay their pensions
anymore and so
you're a free agent and you're always
going to be a free agent on the market
you guys are the kevin durants and
lebron james you know where you're
always out there
and can go find a better situation for
yourself
do what's best for you what have you got
to lose like when i started my company
you know after i got fired by michael
umeki um
um you know what how bad could it be
i would lose my motel 6 towel you know
it was just like what have you got to
lose and yeah i understand there's
pressures from student loans and there's
a lot of conversations we can have there
right but you know you can get a job
that doesn't have to be perfect
you can learn at that job and you guys
have the pedigree you have the brains
you have the initiative to go out and
try the next job
you know you know the good news is the
economy is good enough that it may not
be perfect but you can go job to job
don't look for the perfect answer just
look to get the experience look to learn
because all these different exposures
all the different things you learn
learning how to learn
that's what's going to give you get you
excited and juice you for for something
that you love
because once you find something you love
to do
that's when the magic happens because
when you're when you're
able to find something you love to do
then you can start work focusing on how
can i be great at this
and like greg found out he was a great
networker i like to you know
play with technology and try to do
things first you know whatever it is
that you find about yourself
then you can try to be great at it and
it's rare when people quit
things they're great at you know and so
trying those things
so that that's how i advise people don't
don't stress just go out and try
different things
there's this culture in silicon valley
that kind of
makes startups seem glamorous and
i never really believed that right i
never had a goal of starting
a startup and my goal
when i realized that i had a company was
to get it to be
a good company as quickly as possible
right and kind of get out of what you'd
call the like risky
startup phase where you are just like
constantly about to die
and where you could get to a point where
you can actually do some interesting
things and make make a lot more
interesting bets
and um so i don't know i never read a
lot of the literature on this and i mean
maybe if i had then i wouldn't have made
so many mistakes
but so i don't know if like if learning
for me is the right way to go on this
but
i mean but it did i think your model
must have come from somewhere though
even
if it was even if you it was
unintentional right like were you
influenced by peter thiel
or sean well yes i was people seeing all
these people
once i met them i actually i hadn't
really heard of peter thiel before
i'm talking about like me yeah right
yeah he was massively influential on my
thinking right i mean i
like a lot of the uh the early lessons
that i took
on how to think about strategy came from
peter and sean
and um i did pay a lot of attention when
i was growing up to microsoft i thought
i mean i grew up you know using you know
windows 3.1 and then windows 95 and i
just thought that those were like
the most unbelievable things and uh in a
sense they are
yeah they really really were awesome
right um well i don't know if you you
meant that posit
positively but i did um and and i
thought you know building this ecosystem
was really neat and that kind of
inspired me right
in the way that they built a platform i
kind of thought okay well maybe one day
you know the tools that i'm building can
be part of a broader ecosystem
as well you need to hustle while you
wait if you can embody
this advice and apply it to your
business on a day-to-day basis
this will be the biggest momentum shift
in your company this will move you so
close
to your goals at an incredible pace that
is unbelievable
just most people don't do it hustle
while
you wait listen with every goal that you
have
it relies on other people you need other
people to be a part of your process
right if you're selling to customers you
need the customer to say yes they have
to make their decision
there's a bunch of back and forth if
you're waiting on a product to come
you're waiting on your supplier to come
forward
there's always things that are outside
your control that you're waiting other
people for
and yes when it comes to you you want to
get it done as soon as possible
if a customer is asking for a quote you
want to get it off your plate asap you
should not be
the bottleneck in momentum happening in
your business that's a whole other
problem
as soon as something comes to you it's
getting taken care of and you're
building momentum
but you're still even at the most peak
efficiency
waiting for other people to take action
that's gonna happen so what do you do in
those moments
you hustle you build new momentum you
build
new clients you build new relationships
you maintain the existing ones and get
everything done as soon as possible
and then in the downtime while you're
waiting for a decision
you're not just twiddling your thumbs
you're not just sitting on the couch
you're not watching netflix
you're off hustling new business quick
example
i was doing a photo shoot with richard
this guy's a celebrity photographer he's
done lady gaga i've done the whole bunch
of rappers
he came over and we did a photo shoot
together and in between his shots he's
got to set up lights he's got to
get his fog machine going he's got to
get the right angle he's got to set up
the green screen
and so when he needs me i'm there i'm
ready i'm posing i'm in action i'm ready
to go
but there's a lot of setup in between
shots and so what am i doing
i'm pulling up my phone and i'm
responding to you guys i'm making videos
i'm doing responses i'm getting on
twitter on instagram i'm doing on
snapchat
i'm sending out video responses to you
guys
i'm working i'm hustling on my downtime
while i'm waiting for rich for this
project
i am hustling connecting with you guys
and that's the approach that you need to
take
people say well how do i find the time
to respond to people on social media
i probably have a way bigger counts than
you guys do and i find the time because
i make the time in between the other
things that i'm doing
this is so critical people are losing so
much time
the answer is not to wake up two hours
early or think that's gonna solve your
problem the answer is you're losing
time every single day you are leaking
valuable time
from your daily schedule and so i highly
highly
highly encourage you to take this
message home while you are working
while people are waiting on you for
stuff you are doing your best to deliver
as soon as possible so that you are not
the bottleneck in your business
but then while you are awaiting other
people you get
your hustle on you continue to build
momentum it is such a hack
to get you closer to achieving the goals
that you have for yourself
stop sleeping while you're waiting for
other people to get back to you
hustle while you wait i think just
generally the the path to leadership
should
not be uh through um
you know basically nba business school
situation it's
it's like it should be kind of work your
way up do useful things
and um you know and there's there's a
bit too much of the
somebody goes to a high-profile mba
school and then kind of
parachutes in as the as the leader but
they don't actually know how things work
you know they could be good at say
powerpoint presentations or something
like that um and they can present well
but they don't actually know how things
work because they do not
um you know they're
they're kind of like just not aware of
what's really needed for
uh you know to make to make great
products um so
i mean i don't want to trash mbas too
much here and i
actually do have a dual undergrad
wharton undergrad and physics
um at upenn so um
you know i have like you know it's i
have direct exposure to
to uh um you know to business school and
i
went you know to do undergrad business
school with with physics
but um and i was a teaching assistant
for two
semesters and i graded mbas and uh
undergrads
um so uh but i think it's just a little
bit too much
like like if people look at mba school
as like i want to parachute into being
the boss instead of earning it and like
i don't think that's
that's good henry ford as you may know
failed twice before he started the
ford motor company in 1903 i mean the
the test isn't whether you get the
greatest
business idea in the world the first
time out the test is whether you
keep learning as you go along what your
strengths are and what you can do for
your customers
what you can bring especially to the
party and to do that
you need you need
the education that that i know you've
received
uh through ten thousand small businesses
but you need a
genuine a genuine desire
day in day out to
delight the customer i've never
i've never seen a business and i've seen
a lot of businesses but i've never seen
one that
delights the customer that
that doesn't succeed i mean what you
want is that customer the next day
when they think do i want to rent a car
or do i want to buy some furniture
what goes through their mind you know
it's the place where they've had a great
experience
being an entrepreneur is great it's a
challenge and it's exciting
but if you get a chance to go and to
learn about the real world with a great
firm
you should do that don't doesn't matter
how much you get paid it doesn't matter
what your title is
i went to solomon rather than goldman
who had both offered me a job
um goldman offered me a job at 14 000 a
year which was a lot of money in those
days
solomon offered me a job at 9 000. i sat
down with the number two guy in the
company john goodfriend and i said i'd
like to come to work here
and he said why i said well because
goldman told me what they wanted me to
do
and when i asked your sales manager who
was doing the hiring what would i do at
solomon he said how the hell would we
know we don't even know who you are
you know we're just hiring you off a
piece of paper or an interview
and who knows what our needs are going
to be down the road and who knows what
your skill sets are you have to find out
in the real world
and that made so much more sense to me
than goldman i made the mistake in my
life of studying people that
appeared to be successful a lot of
people are like that
they appeared to be successful you know
today today in the the
the the times that we live in you know
you can go on instagram it looks like
looks like everybody owns a ferrari
everybody has a rolls royce everybody
looks like they're having the best day
of their life that's that's not studying
that's watching
i want to study people or even even at
conferences you can go to a conference
and watch somebody on stage
and he couldn't he he or she could
present to like they're so successful
but
if you really get behind the scenes
you'll find out there is no success
there it's just a lot
of talking and so i would just strongly
suggest to people to
pick a handful of people and make sure
those people are actually doing
not just saying
you know that they're they're not
talking about success they're actually
doing success every day
and how would you know what they're
doing well you should you would you
would see it in their statistics right
like there's some things you can't fake
yeah you can't fake somebody
uh we're buying 250 million worth of
real estate this month
with my money hard to fake that okay
it's a great instagram post by the way
but you can't fake it there's going to
be a loan
there's going to be a building there's
going to be you know acres and acres of
land there's going to be
people living there like you just can't
fake it so there's a lot of things you
can fake
you know you can make a nice little
quote put it on instagram
people look at it like that's the truth
you know and and uh
the the public is is confused with a lot
of what appears to be the truth
it's not and so i would just tell people
um study people
that have success that are doing it now
also the second thing i would say is
make sure that where you're getting your
advice from them
lines up with where you need advice
right so
warren buffett you know warren buffett
he he's at the
he's at the he's at the tail um
he he's at the tail of his of his
he's probably here right so
here he was doing different things than
he's doing here he he talks about
investing in stocks but he actually
doesn't do it
he doesn't buy stocks he buys companies
yeah
so you got to you got to listen to
people steve jobs right here was one of
the most aggressive
business people that this plan has ever
seen i mean he was barbarian aggressive
so was bill gates but if you talk to
bill gates today
bill and steve steve's not alive
obviously but bill gates today saying
dude i'm giving all my money away money
doesn't matter that's not what he was
saying right here
the oprah winfrey show was number one in
our time slot for 21
years and i have to tell you i became
pretty comfortable
with that level of success but a few
years ago
i decided as you will at some point that
it was time to
recalculate find new territory
break new ground so i ended the show
and launched own the oprah winfrey
network the initials just worked out for
me
so one year later
after launching on nearly every media
outlet had proclaimed that my
new venture was a flop not just a flop
but a big bold flop they call it
i can still remember the day i opened up
usa today
and read the headline oprah not
quite standing on her own
[Music]
i mean really usa today now that's the
nice newspaper
it it really was this time
last year the worst period in my
professional life
i was stressed and i was frustrated and
quite frankly i was
i was actually i was embarrassed
it was right around that time the
president first
called and asked me to speak here and i
thought
you want me to speak to harvard
graduates what i
what could i possibly say to harvard
graduates some of the most successful
graduates
in the world in the very moment
when i had stopped succeeding
so i got off the phone with president
faust
and i went to the shower it was either
that or a bag of oreos
so i chose the shower and i was in the
shower a long time
and as i was in the shower the words of
an old hymn came to me you may not know
it it's by
and by when the morning comes
and i started thinking about when the
morning might come because at the time i
thought i was
stuck in a hole and the words came to me
trouble
trouble don't last always from that hymn
this too shall pass and i thought as i
got out of the shower
i am going to turn this thing around
and i will be better for it and when i
do
i'm going to go to harvard and i'm going
to speak the truth of it
so i'm here today to tell you i have
turned
that network around what are the things
you think about that make companies
successful
in this type of environment um versus
those that struggle
well i think it starts with us having
a long-term view rather than a
short-term view
and always thinking of how we can be
successful long-term by creating value
with for others starting with our
customers
and employees and so
when we look at it that way there's
always uncertainty
so it starts with being prepared with
that and
and recognizing that the future
is unknown and unknowable so the way we
have
prepared ourselves for that is focusing
on building capabilities that will be
make us successful under a whole variety
of conditions which means
having more flexibility more optionality
more diversity and so those are the
things
that we've always tried to do and so the
starting point
is is building capabilities that will
enable us to create value with others
starting with our customers
and then finding the opportunities
or the sets of customers for whom we can
create the most value
and then as we do not resting on our
laws but
recognizing the future is going to be
different than the past
then continually improving and adding to
those capabilities
and as we do then we see oh with those
capabilities
we can now pursue additional
opportunities
and then as we start pursuing those
opportunities we realize well we need
additional capabilities so we add still
more capabilities
so this creates what i've called a
virtuous cycle of mutual benefit
where it's continual improvement
and growth and and diversity
i think uh we should think of altruism
giving as a strategy for happiness
forget forget whether the morality of it
all
you know that's the right thing to do
instead
think of it as something totally in your
self-interest
if you can help others you will feel
great the more you can help the more
intelligently you can help
the bigger lever you can get on the
world to make it better
the better you will feel about yourself
the more
joy you will experience you know that is
the road to bliss that is the
intelligent pursuit of happiness and and
that is what we you know that is what we
should do
that is my argument for giving your
dream is possible
the business you want to build the life
that you want to lead the impact that
you want to make
it's possible it really is even if
nobody
like you has done it before there are a
million reasons why
your idea will not work and eat why it
will
which side you choose to focus on will
determine your life
so i'm an introvert that may be hard to
to realize or hard to tell because when
i get on camera when i'm talking
entrepreneurs i get excited i get
animated
uh but i'm an introvert at heart i don't
talk to people on the airplane i hate
networking events
being in big groups causes me anxiety
i'm
super awkward and you know don't know
what to say whenever i'm
kind of put into a group i'm not the
life of a party i'd rather be by myself
and so i'm very introverted and i used
to believe
that that would be a big roadblock for
me if you look back on
on the history of my helping
entrepreneurs as
my website and then my youtube channel i
always hid
behind the the famous people i always
hid behind
sharing my story because i didn't think
it was relevant or as
important or powerful like hey you got
this chance to learn from elon musk who
cares about
evan carmichael and for the longest time
on my channel
evan carmichael's top 10 rule of success
was the number one request
and it always blew my mind like why who
cares
right i mean all these great stories why
does it matter about me
and i was always reluctant to share my
story and i always felt like
because i'm an introvert i don't know
how this is going to work out
when i when i look to people who've done
it when i look to
other people built big youtube channels
or who are great communicators or
fantastic
on stage they look like they have it all
figured out
i love young les brown he's my greatest
motivational speaker of all time when i
look at someone like les brown
it's hard to imagine him being an
introvert he seems to be always happy
the life of a party has got
stories to share and if i if i want to
be like that i want to be a speaker
i always told myself i can't because i'm
introverted and he's not and so i don't
know how to bridge the gap
and so that's where you know people like
me haven't won before people like me
haven't done it before
at least the ones that i knew of and so
it's easy to say well because it hasn't
been done before now
now you can't do it as well what i
discovered was you know what i still
care about serving
i still care about helping i still want
to make a big impact
i want to i want to be able to touch
people's lives even if i don't
want to small talk and chat with them
and be the life of a party and that is
possible
and once i shifted it to service once i
shifted it to recognizing that
i'm not even here for me i'm not on
stage for me i'm not in this room
for me i'm in this room to serve and
using your perceived weakness as a
strength thinking things like
i'm an introvert so i don't talk much
but i'm a great listener
i'm a fantastic listener i can very
quickly understand
what you're going through and how you're
feeling and now i can use that to
make better content and to help shift
you and move you to where you need to
get
and those things of understanding that
that i am service built and so are you
and that just because other people
haven't done it doesn't mean that i
can't
really help give me the confidence
belief motivation
momentum to keep going there are always
going to be reasons
why you can't win there's going to be a
million reasons right a million reasons
why you can't win
and eight why you will five eight ten
but a smaller amount of reasons why you
will and if you start talking to your
friends and talk to your family and
and compare yourself to other people
you're going to find the same thing of
now there's
three million reasons why you can't win
and it's really just that choice to
figure out which are you going to focus
on
the three million reasons why you can't
win or the eight why you can
now i've got a three-step process i'm
going to walk you through that i think
will really help
set number one is get clear on your
goals you know what what do you want
what's the problem that you're trying to
solve right if you don't have that
direction
it's gonna be really really hard for you
actually to build it so i want to solve
the world's biggest problem i think
people
don't believe in themselves enough i
think everybody has michael jordan
elon musk level talent and something and
chances are it's not what your parents
did it's not what your family did it's
not what you went to school for
something totally different
and step one is actually believing that
that is possible and so i'm trying to
unlock as many people
as possible on my journey fully
recognizing that it's never gonna happen
but trying to unlock as many people
along along my path while i'm still
here on this earth and so having that
clear goal having that clear mission for
what i want to try to accomplish
makes everything else easier so for you
what do you want to accomplish
what's your goal who are you trying to
serve what are you trying to do and try
to get as clear and specific as possible
because having that definiteness of
purpose
gives you the boldness gives you the
confidence gives you
the ability to stand on that rock when
there's
waves are coming at you when you're in
quicksand all around you and
and people throwing a lot of hate at you
if you don't have that rock to stand on
you're gonna get caught up in the storm
your goals your purpose your mission
that's the rock that you need to stand
on step number two is find your eight
ways
so like i said before there's a million
reasons why it's not going to work and
eight while it will
you don't need eight eight is an
abundance of reasons you only need one
of those eight
to work out and so you'll have all those
doubts and all those people in your ear
telling you why i can't work out
stop focusing on why it won't work stop
focusing on what you don't have
stop focusing on why you're not good
enough that's not going to serve you
that's going to keep you
in in molasses land it's going to keep
you in preventing
you from actually moving forward and now
live in a life that you hate right
keeps you stuck you have to focus on the
eight reasons why you can
so for a moment you know close your eyes
and imagine that was possible
and there are even though yes there are
many reasons why i won't there are eight
reasons why
find the eight and spend all your time
all your energy all your effort all your
love
on those eight reasons why it can work
out
even though there's all these reasons
why it won't and then step number three
is build immediate momentum
once you've got your eight what are you
gonna do about it
just finding the eight and writing it
down on a piece of paper or putting down
the comments below that's not gonna
help anything yet the ideation is
fantastic but nothing happens until you
do something
the biggest thing missing for most
people for most entrepreneurs is just
momentum
you've got great ideas you're genius the
stuff in here could change the world
but it's not going to change the world
if it stays stuck in here you've got to
birth it it has to happen you need
momentum
and stop making it so big and impossible
and overwhelming that now you need
millions of dollars in a team and all
this stuff that you don't have
bring it down that that is motivating
that's inspiring that's amazing
right that big mission but bring it down
to what are you going to do right now
what can you do today to actually start
building momentum
don't worry about the perfect plan and
just create immediate momentum
on the eight reasons why you can win so
everybody who's watching this will want
to know how do you take a 12 million
revenue company to roughly 120 billion
revenue company without going public
what is the key
secret to doing that well the secret was
that
that i was as i said i didn't feel
i was fully using my capabilities so i
read everything i could from all
different
all relevant disciplines all different
perspectives
to find principles that i could use
and apply in the business in my life to
enable me to believe in myself and i
started to apply them in business
and they worked they worked beyond my
belief
and beyond anything i hoped for and that
absolutely transformed my life and so my
whole life has been
looking for principles that'll enable me
to contribute
uh or improve the the principles we're
implying
and better apply them and
and so every day is like i'm reborn
showing up means
showing up it don't mean you got to the
office
you understand it doesn't mean you came
to work
for me showing up means i show up i've
been showing up since i was
25 years old man before that i wasn't
showing up
i was showing off i was acting a fool
being a fool
high school i didn't show up i went to
class i never showed up
my body went in the room see showing up
doesn't mean you got there showing up
means you got there
and then you showed up again and then
you showed up again and you showed up
again
means you show up for the class you show
up for the homework you show up for the
class you show up for the homework you
show up for the test
you freaking get a perfect grade means
you keep showing up to the next level
and i hear a lot of people talking about
showing up you know showing up's not
everything let me tell you something
showing up when you show up the right
way
johnny you got to put your seatbelt on
when you show up the right way when you
show up the right way
showing up is 100 of success
that means you show up and then you show
up again you show up again you keep
getting better at your game
you can't keep showing up as the old you
you got to show up as the new you you
know mercedes-benz
if they just kept building this vehicle
the way they used to build it
and didn't keep showing up with new
technology
new suspension new seats
new choices new colors
you know the matte black the red guts
new navigation system got to have a new
game every day baby you gotta have a new
game every day and the follow up you
gotta have
you gotta have a new follow-up you can't
have a new i can't can't do the same
thing you did that didn't work yesterday
we're doing a 10x growth conference i'm
doing a 10x this year i'm not doing the
same 10x i did last year it's a new year
new time new audience
new speakers now that being said when i
show up for the 10x growth conference in
las vegas on 220
2020 i just spent six hours this morning
working out what we're doing
okay i'm not going to show up the way i
did last year jumping out of a damn
plane
let me show up in a different way okay
in a different way
in a unique way but i am not going to
abandon the things that work for the
audience and for myself
so you got to find this really really
cool mixture between
repeating what works and showing up as a
new person
all the time if you're reading a book
okay you're listening to music going to
an event
uh speaking at an event
let's say you're speaking in events it's
the 700th time you did that presentation
you got to show up
new again johnny comes to work with his
camera
we're doing a show today johnny needs to
show up new looking for new angles new
colors new
you got to show up every day new folks
you're new man you're new
ladies and gentlemen you're new every
day you're new
or guess what you're old
[Music]
nobody wants old i don't want to get old
i don't want stale i don't want
yesterday's
i don't want leftovers i don't i don't i
know i know when somebody's repeating
something wrote
they're just giving me the same i don't
mind some
but it's got to be fresh i need some
fresh [ __ ]
so i don't i don't mind a little bit of
[ __ ] i just don't want the same
thing
okay that guy's told that story a
thousand times and it looks like the
thousand
thousand times not in a good way either
so you gotta keep showing up showing up
means you're looking for deeper levels
to show up to pay attention
that's what i do every day every day i
come to work i'm like show up man show
up for every little problem
show up for every little opportunity
show up for every little
little new nuance little angle
little particle little movement that's
why i see all this stuff
why is that not cleaned up why is this
not cleaned up what's it why did
somebody pick that up
who's that new person here hey you
feeling all right today how many times
have i asked you that before you all
right
today i know it's little things
it's simple it costs nothing to do this
show up
it costs you nothing and it makes all
the difference man showing up
you'll see things that no one else sees
and and you know the good news is
anybody can do this you just got to make
a commitment to show up
everybody just defines success
differently you know i've always told
people that
if you can wake up in the morning with a
smile on your face excited about your
day
knowing it's going to be a good day
you're successful
and so in terms of your business you
know you got to live at
some level right but if you love what
you're doing and you
love it's not work right i mean we're
not again
all these stories if there's too many
stories no television shut up
um early on i had to teach myself how to
program
and you know whether it's basic c plus
plus
database applications and i would start
you know writing these applications for
customers
and i start working on it working on it
working on it and i look up and i've
been sitting there for 24
26 hours not realizing you know that
i i hadn't moved this whole time i loved
what i was doing
now i was sleeping six guys living six
guys in a three-bedroom apartment
i was starving right you know i had a
hole in the floorboard of my car
but i knew that you know there was a
light at the end of the tunnel
if i kept on getting better at what i
did but had i not had the financial
success i still would have loved it
think things out for yourself come to
your own judgments don't simply
conform uh to conventional ways of
thinking conventional ways of dressing
conventional ways of acting that a lot
of this
a lot of things are are based on fashion
even morality at times is based on
fashion
it was once you know slavery was once
not considered not to be immoral
uh you know people are you know people
are shocked that
the uh the ancient greeks had slaves
that that we had slavery in this country
as recently as
you know 130 140 years ago so
there are more moral values you have to
really go back to first principles and
think
things out for yourself whether they're
scientific principles or moral
principles or
business ideas or product ideas you have
to think things out for yourself
there are very concrete habits that you
can use
that i have used once you get your mind
in the right place once you believe that
it can happen
this is what i did i worked out why
because it helped me gain control of my
mind
one it was micro credibility with myself
every day i said i was going to do
something i did it
two when you're suffering and you're
willing to fight through it you tell
yourself a story
that you're willing to pay the price to
become what you want to become and also
and this may be the most important
reason each and every one of you should
start working out and it has nothing to
do with living longer because we could
get hit by a meteorite who knows
so i'm not even worried about that but i
am worried about this
when you watch your body transform you
get the loudest signal from your
subconscious that you can
change that you can change anything you
want that you can change your bicep your
tricep your quad whatever it is you want
something that you literally could not
do the day before you can do
today and your mind
sees that that's true
your mind sees that something you
couldn't pick up yesterday you can pick
up today
and it begins to ask itself well if
that's possible then what else is
possible
now for me finding my center was also a
very important thing so i work out first
the next thing i do without fail is
meditate
i do a just breathe meditation where i'm
simply trying to calm my mind
then i do what i call thinkitating
during meditating
i get into an alpha wave state brain
pattern which enhances creativity and
unique connections
i'm not worried about whether i'll ever
think a unique thought i'm simply
interested in the unique connections
that i will make
that no one else before me or after me
will ever make because their
circumstances are different than mine
and that to me is what makes each of us
a beautiful snowflake
is we're all going to make connections
that other people might not make
and so during thinking i take advantage
of a problem i'm trying to solve
i smash it together with my alpha wave
state and i see what comes out of it
i read i read obsessively because i
believe in one simple math equation
ideas in equal ideas out and then i keep
a list of the most important things i'm
trying to accomplish
if you're trying to become something you
need to know what that something is
there's a big difference between saving
and investing
saving you don't even beat the inflation
rate anymore basically
that's the amount of cash you should
have on hand just in case poopoo hits
the fan
catastrophic illness in your family car
accident something tragic occurs
i like to have 90 days of
window so whatever it costs you to live
for a month
have three of those just in case poopoo
hits the fan
so 90 days but then you should find a
way
to change your expending habits and you
know the people
spend money on all kinds of crap they
don't need you look at your
closet full of clothes you never wear
anymore shoes you don't wear it anymore
and all the junk you don't need in
consumer electronics take a little bit
of that and just
invest it not save it invest it and that
is where you take and use an app like
beanstalks
to pull 100 bucks out of your account
and automatically put it into a wide
diverse portfolio
that you hope will achieve six to eight
percent a year over a long period of
time
that's how you become a millionaire when
you're in your 60s and you have a nest
egg
that you can fall against when you want
to retire i think
empathy seeing the world through others
and the ability to communicate it you
know it's
the world it's not size anymore
size does not protect you and so it's
new ideas and
i think many people in finance were so
focused on the balance sheet
or income or results from the past
rather than what the future was like
great leaders can take a difficult
situation turn around and make it good
poor leaders can take a good situation
and have it deteriorate
there is this leadership of change
and so to me i always focused on what
was not on the balance sheet and that is
the talent of the management
and the talent of leadership you know a
leader has to convince
people to follow them and have that
passion and vision and you can see it
in their eyes i'm sure you see it in the
short presentations on
chartrank but there is a difference
between and
once capital was no longer
constrained which occurred during the
1970s and 80s
if you look at the united states small
and medium companies created 62 million
jobs
in the last third of the 20th century
and large companies created minus four
so now the large company didn't have the
protection that they were the only one
who had access to capital so
to me who is the leadership what is
their vision what is their commitment
and you have one to your left here
that we would all follow around the
world
if you want to learn these seven habits
of self-made billionaires check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there there are a lot of things that are
a waste of time you know when you think
about your life
i think i i often tell people that i
work with
if you can get because people